hey guys so today I have two very
special guests on the channel and we're
gonna be discussing the season finale of
my year academia season 4 as well as
whether the entire season as a whole
lived up to what we were expecting now
if you're subscribed to me then you
probably already know who these guys are
but on the channel we have true hero and
zonin so how are you doing guys what's
up fantastic
I hope everyone is okay during this
quarantine so we've decided to come
together give you that extra premium
content yes the inside and watch YouTube
exactly
so yeah I mean I guess we should start
with like the pro hero Ark so um
obviously I know you guys have already
seen like the episode yesterday I saw
some people on Twitter saying that this
to them was the best episode of micro
academia they've ever seen
that's that's not my personal opinion
but what do you guys think is this the
best episode of miner academia that has
ever existed I don't know but I think
the best episode we had was the one
where the Ares jumping into Decker's
arms I think that was over the rest of
season 4 but it was a good episode I'm
I'm trying to think of if it was even
condensed a little bit because in the
manga that fight felt way longer like
for actors at least it was I think he's
like 5 chapters right yeah and they
usually - you know unless there's some
huge deku monologue like four chapters
in an episode so I get how they fit it
in but I'd say the ending was more weird
than anything like they ended well you
mean like the post-credits yeah it was
just the the advertisement for season 5
but it's kind of weird cuz season 5 is
gonna start maybe you're with endeavour
being like interviewed or something and
then shows up so oh wait are we doing
spoilers in this mmm I mean I guess we
are now yeah so I I kind of felt weird
about how it ended I just felt a little
compressed yeah yeah I mean to be honest
when I was watching it didn't feel
compressed but if you were told me we're
gonna
the entire pro hero arc in these two
episodes I would have been like there's
no way like you're not gonna do the
whole thing because the pro Yurok is
what like ten chapters I think is that
right like around ten chapters or more
than that so yeah it didn't feel
condensed to me but I don't know like if
he looks at it on paper you'd be like
all that you know they probably rushed
it but I didn't feel like that to me
which is a good thing yeah I mean I was
actually thinking that the original
question that we had here like is this
the best episode I was thinking that as
I was watching this I was like is this
the best episode this is incredible and
then it's like they had it's pretty darn
good but my favorite episode is I forget
the exact number of it season three
maybe episode 12 or something like that
the United States the smash episode that
can't beat Trump to me yet I mean it
will eventually but oh all my first all
for one yeah I mean the conclusion yeah
incredible to this day I mean I I always
get chills watching that or whether I'm
reading it it's like the Almighty
Oh might he has his fist Barry's come on
man come on you know what that actually
might be my favorite as well cuz that
was the episode I remember when a grand
Torino he was like giving that little
speech like just after I think all might
be all for one and I remember like the
first time I watch that I got like
serious goosebumps add that other speech
the grand Torino was giving but um what
forget one question actually had for you
guys do you I know we've been watching
it in sub because you know that the dub
is delayed but do you guys normally
watch the dub or do you always watch
disabled or both how does it work for
you guys I love the dub big big fan of
dub in general I've only really seen the
sub except for like the first season I
watched and dug before I really like
found other websites but yeah it kind of
reminds me that dub gets such like a
negative connotation to it and it's like
alright first of all you don't have to
gate keep anyone because you prefer the
sub over the dub if you have that
opinion that's fine all good but don't
they don't try to gate keep us don't try
to prove that you're like this grandiose
purist it's like dude I get that the dub
has a bad name because of four kids and
all that stuff but that was like over
and
years ago times have change we have a
whole new generation of talent that
actually want to do it for the art and
they're not just collecting a paycheck
so we get fantastic performances like my
hero namely I think one of the best
continued like battle anime dubs
currently right now this is gonna be a
little controversial I'll say that I
think that my hero dub is just as good
as the sub so okay whoo hot it's burning
my hands I can't even hold this take
like hated on subversive I just kind of
prefer the sub because it's in its
native language I always think that
makes it sound better I don't know yeah
you're going to get a lost in
translation but yeah do you do you know
a bit of Japanese I remember on Twitter
you were saying like you're learning or
something I don't mean just from
watching anime but I'm learning Korean
all right right okay smart man yeah I
mean this is the puppet time to do it
right we're at home literally like you
can barely go outside so this is a good
this is a good time but um yeah for me
personally though like I am more of a
sub guy because like when I was growing
up watching anime like on the TV it was
only sub I mean I mean sorry dub they
wouldn't pay like the Japanese version
it would always be like the English
version so that's generally what I
preferred and I find from my hair
specifically like the dub actors are
just most of them are perfect for their
characters especially like I was
thinking endeavour and fat gum and
characters like that like it just fits
the way the character looks so well so
these last few weeks when there's been
no dub whatsoever you know I don't mind
the sub actually I quite like it but my
preference is personally dub but I'm
moving on so in terms of there are
certain things in the pro hero arc that
were surprising to me so the first one
was the voice of the high end I don't
know what you guys thought about this
but it was almost like I mean I guess
it's inhuman right because it's not a
human creature but I was surprised at
the way they sounded I don't know what I
was expecting but that wasn't it I don't
know about you guys I agree with you
100% that's the first thing I thought of
I was like okay I did not expect his
voice to sound like that
I don't know if first I mean we all have
different experiences when we're reading
manga similar to reading a book you know
that's why everybody has like a
different expectation of what you know
the adaptation of what the source
material is going to be because we all
have our own like personal moment like
our own intimate recreation of the
events and this I don't know his voice
kind of sound like it'd be more
high-pitched to me and maybe a little
quicker talking to but his voice it came
out sounding like some kind of like I
don't know hentai devil or something
like I was gonna say it sounds like that
devil site like voice effect like oh you
will and I don't know I always just
thought it would sound kind of like some
creepy or insane villain you know just
with a memorable voice you know like
shigaraki z-- but obviously not you know
better than his but I mean I get it like
it's it's a weird creature so who knows
I mean you could have had them sound
like that thing in Harry Potter like the
snake so you know yeah yeah yeah no I
get that in terms of I mean truth you
mentioned it earlier but after the end
credits we got you know that a
foreshadow for season 5 with Deku and
like the vestiges and everything yeah I
mean that took me out by surprise I
generally wasn't expecting that but in
terms of how season 5 is now going to
pick off so I guess we weren't we
weren't talk too much in spoilers just
for people watching you you know on
until that but um in terms of where
season fives gonna pick off do you think
it's gonna be like we're gonna go on
that and then we're gonna flashback to
where endeavor do you think is gonna be
like a flashback or we are we just gonna
pick up straight where and ever left off
um I'm trying to remember how season 4
started because these are full started
with that filler episode we they all
kind of you know I think season 2 right
they've started with see filler episodes
so it's kind of like a tradition now so
I guess that's how season 5 will start
as well mm yeah I guess the thing about
the season 4 one though it wasn't a
straight recap like I'm sure you guys
have seen it but like it was almost like
its own contained story and I feel like
for season 5 just because of the
cliffhanger of Endeavour defeating this
high end and then the other cliffhanger
of deku with these vestiges there's no
real way you can have a original you
know anime original story like it would
just
it would take me out of it I'd be like
there's two there's two things that we
have to wrap up endeavor and you know
Dec coming the vestiges so why are we
having a filler episode to begin with
yeah I mean I don't know possible they
might do like a half and a half where
dekhi was just talking about here a
society and then it slowly transitions
into the number one hero and then you
see him sort of after the fight and then
you know what happens next and the manga
transpires I honestly think that was
just a teaser especially because it
happens after the credits and I know
that they've you know have a recurring
theme thinking about the seasons where
they do after credits things but I think
that this is kind of just like a little
teaser preview that's like hey look
we're gonna get more into the messages
but I think once season five starts then
it'll just pick up with like you know
Hawks consoling Endeavor them getting
reacquainted and everything and then
shows up and all that stuff I mean I
just think that's probably good and then
it'll just play out accordingly like
when we get to the vestage stuff episode
then that will play out I'd be surprised
if they kind of try to do this flip-flop
thing unless it's to account for time
crunching which seems to be like a
priority of theirs nowadays interesting
enough how we were talking about how
they're you know cramming all these
effort all these chapters in the two
episodes which was unexpected because I
don't know the majority of the fan base
just thought that the pro-hero arc was
gonna happen at the beginning of season
five but another thing before I get like
too scatterbrained here turtle I
guarantee ya that when we saw the
messages for the first time you were
definitely scoping out what colors the
first time oh yeah yeah yeah I mean we
sort of in the heros rising movie right
so I was looking for it then I don't be
see the second message was like red and
I think the third one was like Popple
right it looked like to me like the
first one and the second one where I
mean whoever's here has seen your video
right so can we just like yeah okay so
baku goal of thread Thank You Shima
looks purple that's the way that it
looked like to me yeah yeah I mean I the
thing is with the cursing me being
purple that kind of indicates maybe that
it might not be him
which might be I mean it's probably the
case to be honest but because Kirishima
if he is a vest
he would likely be read I would assume
you know read write and everything so um
I'm kind of thinking that's might not be
him but in terms of back and go I mean
nothing yet has deviated me from that
you know that train of thought but maybe
if we get new evidence soon then you
know I'll think of something else but
right now yeah everything I'm seeing is
saying back ago so I can use it but I
don't think I've ever asked you guys
like what did you what is your like
proper opinion on that I do you think
it's plausible you know the whole area
time-travel thing or no no I just don't
well I mean I just don't think you would
go like that just from a story
perspective but also I just don't know I
mean unless we get some new evidence of
how Aries quirk works and you know we do
get a little more evidence later on on
the manga but that has nothing to
suggest that she can actually rewind
time so I mean I'm still a holdout on
baby steps man baby steps because I put
up with vigilantes recently like a
certain character in vigilantes whose
quirk at the at the start seems like one
thing and by that you know when you're
fully up today it's like completely
different so uh vigilantes to me it just
showed me how how much require can
change from what we initially think I
think is a good example of that but well
I mean we've even had that in my hair
academia I'm not gonna spoil anything
but from the my hero my villain academia
orc we know that quirks me very
different yeah that's true as well
alright but my thoughts on on this
theory is that yes I mean come on
Baca go and Kirishima that's definitely
them in the vestige I mean if that's not
them then what the hell is going on it
looks exactly like them like entity in
the shadows so there's something going
on here as for Aaron's time travel
vehicle I think it's possible
now am I saying it's guaranteed to
happen no but I think there's a really
good chance that it could be something
like that because obviously
we know that eyes out all right well I'm
getting in the spoiler stuff but you
know what Aizawa has done in the pre in
the recent stuff I think that might be
leading to that possibly happening
because there has to be obviously a
connection for them to become the first
and second users yeah yeah or as
possible there's maybe I used I mean a
quark user that we haven't seen yet
because I mean night I was introduced in
what season four and obviously he can
see into the future so I mean I kind of
spoke about this on Twitter already but
night I in a sense he altered the future
by seeing into the future because by
using the future to affect your
decisions in the present day that then
creates a new reality essentially so
that's one way that night eyes
manipulated time but very plausible
didn't I go I'm either no matter what he
did he couldn't change the future no so
he believed that was the case that's
what he thought and only suddenly dec
who altered it exactly yeah
so once Decker Walter did that proved
tonight I liked when he died he kind of
accepted that the future could be
changed yeah but yeah his belief up
until that point was that yeah it
couldn't be changed yeah so there could
be a user in the future potentially who
may just straight-up have time travel
not even you know not even any strings
attached for that but um that's it I
guess that's a discussion for another
time so getting back to season four in
terms of like you guys highlights and
lowlights so we may as well start with
the highlights so for me personally one
of the things that I was most
anticipating for the season and I think
to most people this is probably every
small moment as it only took a few
seconds but overall when he exploded
Magna in like I think the second episode
I that was something that I had been so
hyped just to see and when I eventually
saw it animated like they did it so well
it is so nice oh bloody as well I think
I thought the what the skin on Magnus
arm bubble yeah it's like Cody put it in
the black-and-white too which is nice it
looked it looked like the manga panel
coming to life yeah I think they may
have done it better than a magnet I
think they made the knee better because
the way as Magna was like drawing
overall closer to tour and then you see
over like slowly taking off his glove oh
man everything about it was epic but uh
I had a few other moments which will
maybe get to in a bit but Autopia
what is both of you like what is one
thing out of the season that just stood
out to you I mean come on we're all
thinking it
the 100% beat down I mean like the way
that the anime took liberties with it
was well done also let me just say that
I think the anime is better than the
manga for my hero not saying the
Mongoose not bad it's obviously
fantastic one of the best in the game
right now but I've always thought the
anime has done it better because they've
adapted things better
they've given they've shed more light on
things that may be needed you know more
light shed on them definitely especially
with this endeavour fight recently we
got at least when he was like tangling
with Hawks we got to get a better
understanding of how that went down but
the 100% beatdown of overhaul incredible
and then you know like the the additions
that I was saying like how the fight
kind of gets extended because in the
manga it's real short it's kind of like
what 1 and a half pages it's just these
Duke who goes 100 beats him down and
that's it but in the anime they kind of
extend it a little bit we have that
moment where like overhaul comes
together and he has like the big hands
and the big arm at the moment and then
the whole thing with Ares hair you know
I'll suffer it out behind these ooh goo
when the shadow takes over them and you
just see his eyes and the air behind him
that is like incredible the way they
made that in the anime so yeah that's
dense that my favorite moment aside from
Leon what happened in episode 25 yeah
that moment it looked like deck it was
tapping into the dark side the sake and
I'm sure horikoshi loves that I mean the
other episode 2 was when it was more you
know just how they used the music in the
in the anime when Ares jumping in the
deck his arms you know and he's just not
giving up like he always does so it was
that was all your highlight for like the
season yeah that in the end deck is 100%
fight yeah man I mean in terms of like
the lowlights now so you guys know I'm a
massive mirror fan you guys know that
and the mirror fight was actually pretty
good up until the quote-unquote slide
show that that we all saw now that was a
bit jarring for me especially as later
on in the season we see you know deku
how amazingly animated
was when you know he was being done
overall and then obviously the episode
the other day with endeavor what did you
guys think of that whole you know a bit
of an inconsistency in the season yeah I
know we were talking about and I think
maybe that's what they wanted for that
scene I was gonna say something like
okay you know maybe we could chalk this
up to like budget constraints because
not every episode could be a banger not
not even every other episode could be a
banger they kind of have to us you know
not spread themselves too thin and that
might have been an example of this but I
think maybe that's what they wanted they
wanted to keep it concise maybe a little
ambiguous because that's kind of how it
plays out in the manga cuz it's kind of
just like a narration it's like and then
myrio fought for i don't know however
long what 10 15 minutes or something
with no core yet he was still winning so
maybe he just wanted it to like just get
that point across and maybe not show too
much but rather just tell you but I
agree with your initial thought there it
could have definitely been done better
but I don't know maybe it was just a
little confusing to the you know the
general people watching it if it wasn't
like you know on a grand scale the way
that everything else was yeah it was a
bit inconsistent in terms of animation
quality well I mean I guess that final
episode I mean people are literally like
I said saying is the best episode
they've ever seen so I mean it was
trending right so yeah really I'm
worldwide with what endeavour yeah I
mean I wonder how all those true fans
feel now you know I'm saying well the
wolf ends the true my her academia fans
you know the ones that horikoshi death
threats you know not us you know we're
not yeah I do I do wonder about that
come season 5 how they'll react to
everything I thought it was good all
might was great he looked very just oh
my was like whenever is he's another guy
get kicked in the nuts and they're like
yeah yeah all might was feeling for him
though in the manga they had that final
panel of endeavour with his wings doing
prominence burn into the nomas mouth
they
after that perfectly oh yeah for sure I
feel like they went above and beyond for
certain parts oh the bit when he's
actually taking high end up into the sky
basically in I couldn't remember the
manga panel exactly but in the anime he
it was almost like he was going close to
space like he was super high up and I
don't know it felt it felt way higher
than what I remember it being from the
from the manga definitely I don't know
if you guys maybe thought that yeah I
think that's a Liberty that they took
with that just to make a little more
grandiose yeah yeah I liked it I was
awesome one punch man stuff yeah take no
mood to the moon I mean they already
were like kind of creeping in the one
punch territory with the the fists that
Deku was doing at the end of the overall
fight oh yeah yeah I was actually not
expecting that as well but I loved it
yeah that was that was great yeah so in
terms of like other highlights for
season 4 so for me personally I mean I
already mentioned like the overall thing
but in terms of like the infinite 100%
battle which you mentioned zone in that
bit when you like zoomed in on overhauls
I do you guys remember that bit yeah we
did it yes pupil sclera you see
everything yeah that was really awesome
I've never seen that kind of detail I
don't think I've ever seen that kind of
detailing this before that that's
usually reserved for like movies and
stuff yeah it was kind of like movie
level quality like that fight when
especially when he like how do I
describe it like he was getting the
impact from dec whose punches like late
I don't know if you guys couldn't know
what I mean like it was almost like
Debbie punched him yo yeah then it's the
the aftershock it's kind of I guess it's
to imply like he's moving so fast that
like not even the viewers can comprehend
it or he's using air force oh oh
spoilers I like I like the overhaul I
part cuz in that moment overhaul there's
only one thing he's like oh I messed up
good see it in his eye you know it's not
as funny but he's definitely like
crapping his pants and you know you just
reminded me of something so the whole
cultural festival arc now I think people
who subscribe to me they know this
already but that is
not one of my favorite arcs in the
series though I appreciate like its
place because it is quite important in
terms of Airy so when I was watching
that whole arc like I wasn't really too
into it but I want to get your guy's
opinion on it so like what did you think
of the culture festival how was it done
what did it live up to expectations or
no I think it's a nice reprieve from the
whole overall drama but yeah it's never
been one of my favorite arcs
I think the handle gentle and lebra fine
I like them I like how they did their
characters and they also I feel like
they did more with the gentle verse Deku
fight but I'm not sure I can't really
remember it from the manga but it
definitely looked good animated but I
mean in terms of uh like highlights from
it I mean there's zero singing and Aries
smile so yeah every small is the number
one highlight of the season this is only
what did you think of like need culture
festival so I mean I echo your
sentiments turtle on this completely not
the biggest fan of this arc but I
understand its significance I also
understand the demographic that it
caters to me I'm just a bread and butter
battle manga to you like that's it for
me and meat and potatoes when it comes
to this game I'm not really into the
slice of life stuff I don't watch anime
for like the drama or the romance and
all that stuff and you know what to each
his own if you do that's fine I
appreciate some of that stuff like hagia
Summa I think that's a fun little anime
but aside from that I'm just like into
like the interesting adventures the
stories the scaling all that stuff so
when we come to the professed the the
hero festival stuff are the student
festival it's like that's fine I get
that not everyone is like me in this
fandom especially for my hero since it
is one of those different type of battle
mangas it does have elements of slice of
life more so than the other series so I
get that he also has to cater to those
fans and that's fine I know that
everybody enjoyed it I saw it had a
great reception on Twitter and also
something about I don't know how true
this is I never really looked into it
but I've heard it
horikoshi was like going through some
kind of depression while writing the
overhaul our curse or it caused him to
be a little depressed so in order to
like pull himself out of that he
purposely made the student festival to
like I don't know uplift things possibly
well interesting I've never heard that
before have you heard that truth I
haven't I know he's had to take breaks
cuz of stress and depression I know he
when he originally was
I guess drawing things he got really
frustrated because he drew this great
villain shigaraki that has ten hands on
him at all times and he was not good at
drawing hands so unfortunately I'm an
actress off into a corner there but he's
gotten better now actually and that's
why like you'll see in the beginning of
all his chapters you know he does those
like hands inside like a hand oh yeah
yeah that's like he's a car I that's
what yeah so he he always wanted to be
better at drawing hands interesting yeah
but he I mean I know he was frustrated
from that and of course you know what
the true fans tell them all the time the
real one okay guys well before we round
out the video I just wanted to ask you
how are you dealing with like the
situation going on in the world like I'm
not gonna say it but we all know what's
happening you know I'm in a bit of a
lockdown at the moment so how are you
guys finding it I mean I'm so bored not
you know having access to a gym and just
trying to stay inside I mean I can make
videos but um obviously you know YouTube
creators have our own problems with this
everyone has their own problems with
this you know I'm doing okay I'm healthy
I'm fine so that's all that matters but
uh yeah I'm getting a little stir-crazy
man it's such a difficult time just for
everyone like we're all literally
experiencing this together which is the
unique thing about it because usually
like when tragedies or just things like
this happen it only affect like one
group or two groups or something but
it's like every one if this is life now
this is gonna be life for the next month
two months maybe so man it's just uh
gotta stay safe guys washer
don't touch your face and if you have a
mask wear it yeah I mean I don't know if
masked work but I mean I was in between
jobs and like trying to figure stuff out
and I'm like well I'll just do YouTube
in-between and now this happens so it's
been a weird ride for me cuz I'm just
you know I can't really apply for things
but I guess I'll keep making videos and
keep washing my hands I I think that's
kind of like people are expecting now
like now that everyone's at home it's
like people expect content creators to
probably push out more stuff I mean I
know I was expecting myself to be doing
more videos but the place where I work
like they still we still work from home
and stuff so even during the week I
don't actually get as much I thought I
have like so much more time to make
videos but in reality actually pretty
much the same which is annoying which is
unlikely I do want to make more videos
but yeah I mean okay guys well thank you
so much for coming here on the channel
today I really appreciate it maybe we
can do a collab again in the future
talking about season five or something
if that interest you but um yeah thank
you guys to come in absolutely hey any
time I'm happy to be here happy to talk
about anything with my hero especially
season five there's so much that we
could talk about with that like yeah any
time you want to do this I'm down happy
make the content yeah yeah peace out
guys
see ya stay safe